all regimes
have something to do with religion okay
they have some religious foundation you
look at a place like afghanistan the
religious foundation
is islam
okay no matter what exact government
comes and goes islam is going to be the
basis of it in the west and in america
in particular that grounding originally
was
christianity
right now over time
in america the religion became the civic
religion of say the founding fathers or
of abraham lincoln this is why
on our national mall we have a
greco-roman temple with a giant statue
of abraham lincoln as if he were zeus
okay this is why we have weird obelisks
to the deities of our founding fathers
like like george washington because it
is a civic religion and we at least
until very recently worshipped the
values that they stood for and worshiped
these men as sort of demi gods now now
we're tearing down their statues and
replacing it with a new religion now the
new religion is even more secularized
than the one that we've been laboring
under for a long time
it is the cult of science there is a
band that i had never heard of called
the kaiser chiefs this is an english
indie rock band the lead singer is ricky
wilson he was just at a concert full of
all sorts of people they've got their
hands in the air and he says that's
right put your hands in the air not
hands in the air to feel the music not
hands in the air to feel the spirit
hands in the air to show me how clean
you are because you've gotten your
vaccine
clean hands
washing them
let me hear it you've had the pfizer
vaccine
let me hear it from the donor
astrozenica
[Applause]
see it from the anti-vaxxers
[Applause]
yeah you've got clean hands i can see
it's good
we're spraying it with jello man
all right follow us
that's right they're now calling him not
the kaiser chiefs but the pfizer chiefs
this is really creepy stuff
and it doesn't make any sense unless you
are familiar with religious ritual it's
a sort of religious ritual right with a
great many religious rituals you you
undertake a ritual purification so you
know that you're broken you know that
you're fallen you know that you're
impure but then you go through this
ritual purification and then you are
pure again right and then you go go out
into the world and so this has become a
literal
uh ritual
you know it's not just that you're
cleansing your soul though that's part
of it with this but you're you're
cleansing your body because we live in
this very secular age
and by cleansing your body you cleanse
your soul this is why the anti-vaxxers
are being booed this is why they're
being jeered this is why they're called
deplorable and awful and murderers right
that they're guilty of some sort of
sin some metaphysical crime if they do
not take the fauchiachi and then they're
not clean
really
creepy stuff
but this sort of thing is going to be
inevitable your your society is going to
have some religion or another and if you
don't have
true good normal religion then you're
going to have creepy weird modern
science religion but you're going to
have some religion i'm glad you like
that clip here's what i need you to do i
need you not only to subscribe to the
michael nolshow channel here on youtube
i need you to go to apple podcasts or
spotify or stitcher wherever you get
your podcasts type in
the michael knowles show it's very easy
to type in m-i-c-h-a-e-l-k-w-l-e-s
type it in subscribe leave a five-star
review we really appreciate you see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]